okay let me start with a follow-up about
a story from yesterday yesterday i
showed you the video of this uh coughing
anti-mask woman in a grocery store in
nebraska uh we did not yet have that
much information about her yesterday now
we know much more about her and she has
been fired her name is janine hoskovec
this is an arizona woman
who
used to work for the software company
sap
she has been fired she was in a video
that has gone uh giga viral i would call
it coughing on a mother and daughter who
were shopping at a super saver grocery
store in lincoln nebraska she's done
folks let's review the video first just
so we're all on the same page this is
from yesterday and it is horrifying
excuse me
i'm coming through
vile
vile
[Music]
because i don't need to have one on i'm
not sick and neither are you okay but
you want people how does she know that
you don't know who's tripping
it's my allergies you don't know
enough right by looking forward oh
you've got yeah and so
two years ago before anybody started
talking about kovid you were okay with
that though going out not knowing you
were sick right
you don't know what to write about my
help
i don't yeah janine can you deploy those
new updates to the code
please and she got all freaked out
because i'm popular
no she's kind of how do you know you
don't know and she just said i don't
know anything about her health i don't
know you don't know anything about my
health i actually i maybe i have them
it's funny she 30 seconds prior she says
we don't need masks because i'm not sick
and neither are you and then she says
you don't know anything about my health
or her health already but nobody knows
anything okay so listen she has been
fired she has been fired um sap the
company that she used to work for put
out a statement
after the woman was identified
saying quote the health and safety of
our employees and the communities in
which we live and work are of utmost
concern to us we are taking the matter
of an sap employee incident very
seriously and investigating the
situation going on to say via twitter we
have reviewed the incident and can
confirm that the individual in question
no longer works for sap this is of
course the right decision for sap as a
business they made the decision that was
best for them and janine hoskovic now
can go and uh participate
in the marketplace of employment and of
ideas and there may well be a company
that will hire her because of this
unhinged coughing brandt
or not and that would be the marketplace
of uh ideas and employment that the
right so desperately claims to want so
that is one follow-up
that is a very very good thing and no
word on charges yet we did talk
yesterday about how under nebraska law
one a layman's interpretation of third
degree assault suggests that this could
be third degree assault that's one thing
in addition
in times of covid
one could
argue that federal terrorism charges
could actually be levied against folks
like this for deliberate coughing on
others i don't think we've seen it but
that was a legal opinion that was
floated a few months ago we looked at a
forbes article yesterday that explained
it as of yet
no charges that we know of against
janine huskovec certainly being
judged in the court of public opinion as
the video has been viewed i mean the
original post was viewed more than four
million times
but it's been replicated and duped
that's just on twitter
um between all of the reposts to youtube
and facebook i i assume at least 20
million people have seen this over the
last 48 hours so that's going on
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chilly blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
the link is right underneath this video